I think it's gotta happen again guys. I'm not really stoked about it, but I think we have to move
Laser Boy Hollow again. Landlord has raised the rent. My lease is up in two months and I've already
been struggling here for the past three months. Honestly, it's been tricky. The social media game,
the art game, it's been really tricky and now the economy's going all the way down. So what are we
doing? We got a problem to solve. I don't want to close shop. That's the nightmare for me. We've been
here before. I think the downwards flip has been mostly about me not paying attention to all of
the media things you're supposed to be paying attention to and how you're supposed to adjust
and how you're supposed to do things as well as me severely being adverse to things like the TikTok
shop and other commerce platforms that try and get creators or influencers to sell stupid shit. But
luckily I do have a place to land. So this is the third iteration of the Laser Boy Hollow Laser Lab
situation. I've been comfortable here for two years and now we're on to the next one. Rebuild again.
We got a lot of stuff here. It should be quicker and easier. It's not going to travel 2,000 miles
across the country. We just got to travel about three miles in one direction and then we'll be
all right. So where are we going? To here. New basement. This is the basement of my lovely girlfriends
and these are her kilns. She's a ceramic artist. She's going to be setting up in this side. I'm going
to be on this side. We're going to be kind of dueling it, right? That sounds kind of cool.
I'm going to move stuff and do a lot of stuff and I'm dancing around this pole. Not for money,
but I do need money. Okay, it's been about a week since I shot that first part of this video and now
I just have to get going because I feel like there's specific things here that are stopping me from
getting momentum and getting this place situated so that I can start working in it and start making
stuff for you and all that good stuff. I got to paint it. I don't want to paint it. I got to paint
it though. I think that I'm motivated enough to do it. I hope that I can keep momentum and let's go.
Let's go. Let's go.
Right in the plan of no return. We're going to move here. We're going to move that table and this whole
thing. That means that the next batch of film that I make has to be the new spot. I got a couple
orders that I got to do so it means that we're going to make the rest of this whole thing pretty swift.
So here we are. I think we're about fourth. Boom, here we are. Maybe we should give you a wider view
here. Looks kind of like this. Yeah, I guess we could maybe zoom in a little bit. I don't know
how I feel about this light yet. Maybe it's okay. This is the new lab. So I got to clean some stuff up.
But like I said, let's get to work. It's not going to be perfect. Just better every day, right? So come here.
Here we are. Nice. So this is just how the steps are going to work. We're going to do the live content.
We're going to do recorded content. We're going to do content. All right. That's the name of the game
and the art game today. But the idea here is that to be present. The world is very weird right now.
And I think that artificial, let's say artificial creators do pose a threat to the creator economy
in general. I think there is a way that we marry together with this beautiful future. But right now
it seems like artists are being taken advantage of. AI is only built for tech boys who don't want
to pay creatives. So I'm a mixture of a tech boy and a creative. So I use the technology.
I'm up with the technology. I don't really know how we navigate forward. But I do know
that I need to be present as a human creator. And I think this is how we do it. I think
we'll do this type of content, this type of just open creativity, I think is the concept
that I have in mind. I've got a lot of projects knocking around, floating around. Point of being
is that I don't think that in this world of AI generation and duping other people's work,
there's any value in just posting a final image, right? A final piece of art, right? And showing
the process is really what it's all about. Like, especially what you do with the work that
I do, which is that it's holography and it's not necessarily widely known how it works or
how it's made. I think that's just a way to get ahead of the curve. Get as close to being
undeniably here and human and creative as I can, which seems to be live streaming. This
is what I learned to do on TikTok. TikTok was really cool because I got to like directly
connect with people. Doing the live streams, it was very nice having like a community to
tune into, people that cared, people that were interested. And I just want to keep growing
that even if it's not on TikTok. It's more working on YouTube. We're all seemingly streaming
on other platforms like TikTok too, but I don't think as much. Like, I don't think it's going
to be the primary place. I'm trying to figure out right now, I do have it set up so that I
can stream horizontally like this to YouTube as well as TikTok vertically at the same time.
So that's really cool. I have a system in place where I can be in more places at once
and we can expand that even more. I think that's dependent on my upload speed, my internet here.
So look forward to more online content, live content, that, but it's cool to have a platform
where people can just step in and start asking me questions and I can speak directly to them.
I think that talking to people is a way to talk to them about art. So that's why I always try
when I can to have a call with my clients so that we are on the same page. And sometimes
you get there, sometimes you don't. Anyway, I'm just rambling now. Please tune in. We're
going to do these, I don't know what schedule is going to be, maybe Tuesdays and Thursdays
we're going to be doing so strongly. I don't really know. Maybe suggestions on what people
are available. If you're watching this video, you seem like an interested party. Interested
party. It's Interceptent. I'll catch you later. I'm going to be working on a pendant, a hologram
pendant of a Luna moth. The model is almost done. So this is what we're doing here. This is
what we're doing. It's going to be one of the kind of guillotine style pendants that I make.
I don't know why that's the move. It is now. Sultant. I like what I do here. I'm trying
to get back on all the Instamedias. I think that it was really difficult to operate as me.
I'll just say me. It was difficult to operate as me at the tail end last year. I don't think
that I did well with the news cycle. I don't think that overall I am too sensitive for the news.
I don't know what to do about that other than to continue to translate my emotions into my work.
So internal renaissance, right? I think that I'm just giving myself the authority to step
back into the light, to accept the idea that the things that I create are worth people's
time and they're important. If you've been following me on Instagram for a long time,
found me on TikTok, if you found me on YouTube, I don't care what you found me. I just really
appreciate that trigger. And hopefully we're going to turn this car around. We're going to go uphill now.
Thank you.